yellow tape and scorched earth mark the
place where the ill-fated ethiopian
airliner
disintegrated just minutes after takeoff
flight 302 left the country's capital on
sunday morning
heading for nairobi in kenya but it
never arrived
and there were no survivors all 157
including eight crew were killed in what
eyewitnesses described
as a massive explosion passengers from
dozens of countries lost their lives
including at least 32 kenyans seven
britons
and one person from ireland
the family of dual british national
joseph waitaka
say he is among the dead mr waitaka
spent 15 years of his life in hull
before returning to kenya
in 2015. sarah offray
also lost her life she was a graduate of
the university
of plymouth and a joint citizen of
britain and france
and joanna toole from exmouth in devon
was one of 19 un
staff members who were on board the
plane
her father told sky news he'll never
stop expecting her calls
i've always been worried about her
flying in all the hundreds of flights
she's
taken i've never been that would have
been happy about her going on any of
them but
i did appreciate that she had to do it
in order to
to do her work i suppose it's not the
same situation
as if you know if you had a child who
was
run over in the street out here
where you could come to terms with it
you would understand what had happened
far more readily
i don't think i'll ever
give up expecting her to actually ring
this is the deadliest incident to
afflict ethiopian airlines
but the cause isn't clear the aircraft
was new
the company taking ownership of the
boeing 7378
max just four months ago and the captain
was experienced
the company's chief executive promised a
thorough investigation
we cannot rule out anything we cannot
also attribute
the cause to anything because we will
have to comply with the
international regulation to wait for the
investigation to reveal
the cause of the accident there is
concern over the reliability
of this aircraft after an identical
model operated by lion airlines
crashed into the sea off the indonesian
coast last october
american aircraft manufacturer boeing
said it was deeply saddened
and would assist in the investigation
rescue workers have yet to recover the
plane's flight data recorder
but officials hope it will reveal how
this tragedy
unfolded john sparks sky news
ethiopia